fifteen points again and Kenny's day on
the floor he gambled that time
DeMarcus gets his first foul honor hitch
goes to the line looking for the lead
Leonard they do but this is a nice move
quick decision go right to it cousins
all the way to the rack he's got a guy
contact but Alvin said it's more of a
carry than my guy right there in the
restricted area now trying to defend
bogey who brought an elbow to the side
of his head and got away with it and
DeMarcus Cousins with a nice little flip
guy that doesn't want to really be on
the block to begin with over the top
cousins an easy one good ball movement
good quick decisions look inside but
everything is quick it's hard for the
defense to catch up with the ball
counted four in front of the rim
four-point game
cousins euro-step all the way through
Meyers letter
job is staying out of foul trouble to
this point and other than putting the
team in the penalty that's a big fella
running fast yeah that's getting up and
down the floor 65 59 towels have their
biggest lead up a game
so did McCallum he was all over them
not cousins trying to lose Newark äj--
and does it off the glass one four in
one baggies Rondo little show and go hop
up out handsome cousin staying with it
but that had mustard on it man that past
funny time of the shot clock
[Applause]
cousins held up going to the line
looking for the three-point play count
it and attack the : Meyers Leonard gotta
go
and he will it'll work 18 point lead for
the pelicans with 9.8 to play much time
left you've been in this Jeff of war oh
yeah
it's not a time Darius Miller off to rub
cousins hard to the hole looking springy
instead of the banker at a 12-point game
that's a lot all the way to the hole and
all the way to the free-throw line dick
that's new I mean that's it's nice
hitter on the run-out speak go to the
hole instead it's cousins teen and off a
triple yes frustration in the building
116 102